مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في نيوز الانباء قتل
سبعه استراليين وجرح عشره في هجوم مسلح
شانه فلسطيني في قلب الحي الاستيطاني
النبي يعقوب شماليه قرصه المحتله وصفته
الشرطه بالاعنف من نوعهم منذ سنوات اشارت
تحقيقات الاوليه للشرطه الاسرائيليه لان
الشاب الذي يشتبه انه من القدس الشرقيه
ويحمله هويه اسرائيليه اطلق النار من مسدس
بحوزته بينما كان يقود سيارته قرب كنيس
وسط الحيه صارت السلطات الاسرائيليه الى
الدفع بتعزيزات واغلاق المنطقه بينما اغلق
جيش الاحتلال الحواجز العسكريه التي تربط
القدس المحتله بالشماليه الضفه الغربيه
والجنوبها
ذلك اصدرها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اوامره
لحمايه المستوطنات والاستعداد لاي تطورات
مدنيه اخرى وكان بنغفير ورئيسه الحكومه
هرعلى موقع الهجوم وسط اجراءات امن مشدده
واستقبل المسؤولين حشد اسرائيلي غاضب هتف
باب الموت للعرب وبتحرير المسؤولين على
القيام بعمليه الانتقاميه واسعه ضد
الفلسطينيين
ووصف
بانها هجوم قاسم ومن اصعب بمعرفته اسرائيل
خلال السنوات الاخيره اضاف انه جمع كافه
اجهزه الامن في جلسه تقييم للموقف وتم
اتخاذ القرارات بشان عده اجراءات الفوريه
ردا على الهجوم
تناقش اربع منظمات مدنيه في تونس بين
الاتحاد العام للشغل اعداد مبادره الحوار
الوطني التي ستعرض على رئيس الصعيد ويناقش
الاجتماع تشكيل لجان التي ستعد اوراقا في
الجوانب الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه
من جانبه قال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني في
تونس احمد نجيب الشابي الى اهم طرفا في
الازمه الحاليه هو الرئيس قيس سعيد الذين
قضى على الدستور والحريات حسب وصفه
قال المنسق منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
بلاده تتوقع وصول الدبابات الالمانيه
والاوروبيه في وقت قصير النسبيا مساعده
الاوكرانيين اضاف كير بيانو اصول الدبابات
الامريكيه ابرامز الى الاوكرانيين سيستغرق
وقتا طويلا لكنه واشطا ستبدا بتدريب
الاوكرانيين عليها قريبا حاسبه تعبير
من جهه قال رئيس المسكي ان تاخر وصول
دبابات ابرام الامريكيه حتى شهر اغسطس
يعني وصولها بعد فوات الاوان
بحاجه جديده في اسرع وقت ممكن
في موسكو قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا الزخرفه ان تزويد الغرب
لكيف بالدبابات سيؤدي الى رفع لمواجهه بين
روسيا والغرب الى مستوى جديد
[موسيقى]